the third episode of Game of Thrones
eighth season wasted no time diving into
the action of the Battle of Winterfell
coming in hot and holding nothing back
sure to be remembered as one of the most
epic entries in Thrones history the long
night pitted the living against the dead
the light against the dark and fire
against ice many characters took their
final breaths in the cold Winterfell air
here's a look at the characters who
didn't make it and one big winner the
bodies start falling from the first
swing of a sword even equipped with
flaming weapons and steadfast
determination
the Dothraki aren't men of myths or the
enders of the long night soon after they
forge ahead into the darkness with
John's direwolf ghost charging alongside
them the Dothraki outriders are wiped
out by the whites the sight of the
Living quickly becomes overwhelmed by
the dead Jon and Daenerys send their
dragons wriggle and drogon out into
battle to breathe fire onto the enemy to
little avail the dead aren't dying and
out of this world wind storm clouds
everyone's vision people are dropping
left and right and the episodes first
major death comes when Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch dollar as edy dies via
stabbing when trying to save Samwell
Tarly newly knighted Brienne then orders
the forces to retreat into winter fells
gates the speed at which the battle
devolves into chaos pushes Arya to send
her sister Sansa to the crypts the
so-called safest place in Winterfell
with a dragonglass dagger I don't know
how to use it
sticking with the pointy end in the
catacombs
Sansa joins her former husband Tyrion
Lannister Sam's partner Gilly Varys and
Miss on day plus every woman child and
elderly person in Winterfell
Sansa Tyrion and Miss on day exchanged
barbs before the situation becomes no
laughing matter as fans predicted the
corpses resting and stark family crypts
come back to life and take victims down
with zero difficulty or remorse while
dozens died screaming behind them
Sansa Tyrion Gilly Varys and Miss on day
make it out of the crypts alive and
their survival may spell trouble moving
forward
Tyrion Varys and Masson day are on
Daenerys side they've all bent the knee
and pledged loyalty to her Sansa on the
other hand hasn't warmed up to her yet
and might never once she realizes that
jon is the true heir to the Iron Throne
Theon Greyjoy has done some serious
repenting since betraying House Stark at
the start of the war of the five kings
taking in as a ward and a prisoner of
Ned Stark following his own father's
duplicity Theon grew up in Winterfell
and had long been considered a member of
the stark family fianc treachery against
the Starks reached its apex when he
seize Winterfell in the second season of
Game of Thrones capturing two farm boys
and displaying their burned bodies on
the castles walls passing him off as
bran and Rickon Stark beneath the
weirwood tree in Winterfell is God's
would where bran awaits the night king
bran absolves the on of his sins bran
tells him that everything he's done
brought him to where he is now
home you're a good man the night king
then emerges and Fionna attempts to stab
him with a spear but it's no use the
night king kills Theon with a swift jab
there's a bright side though at least he
died knowing Sansa Jon and finally bran
forgave him several more perished
fighting in the Battle of Winterfell
beric Dondarrion was all out of extra
lives when the white stabbed him
multiple times while he protected Arya
little Lyanna Mormont the ferocious last
from Bear Island who insisted she take
part in the fight dies our heroic death
when she bravely stabs a white Giant in
the eye and is subsequently crushed in a
tan
a Lascar start Falls off-screen she was
among the people protecting brand
alongside fian in the godswood
then came Jorah Mormont he died
defending Daenerys to the bitter end
when a pack of whites unleashed fury on
drogon who takes flight and abandons
Dany the mother of dragons is left to
fight off enemies herself until Jorah
swoops in and protects her from what end
up being fatal blows Dany sheds many
tears over the loyal Jorah as the Sun
begins to rise in the night slips under
the horizon
the red woman Melisandre walks out of
Winterfell stepping between two mounds
of dead bodies like Moses parting the
Red Sea and willingly ends her own life
she removes the red amulet adorned
necklace that perpetually sat around her
throat continues out into the
battlefield and leaves this mortal coil
in season 6 it was revealed that
Melisandre wasn't the youthful woman she
appeared to be she was incredibly old
and the necklace extended her life with
it off for too long she was bound to
succumb to the effects of extreme old
age Melisandre likely felt her work in
Westeros was complete and she may have
been harboring guilt over the death of
little serine Baratheon whom she helped
burn at the stake in season 5 she also
kept good on to past promises she once
shared a prediction with Varys I will
return their spider one last time my
lady I have to die in this strange
country she also told sir Davos at the
start of the Battle of Winterfell that
she would be dead before dawn Arya
didn't just evade death in the Battle of
Winterfell she lengthened the lives of
everyone in the Seven Kingdoms by
killing the night king in the corridors
of Winterfell Melisandre reminds Arya
that she will indeed shut many eyes
forever brown green and blue eyes to a
prophecy as to what aria is about to do
what do you say to the god of death
not today moments after the night King
sticks a spear through fianc torso and
turns his attention to brand aria
suddenly appears behind the frosty
villain he attempts to choke her and her
Valyrian steel dagger Falls but Aria
catches the weapon with her other hand
finds a space in the knight Kings armor
and stabs him there causing him and all
of his underlings to shatter into a
million tiny pieces the night Kings
undoing came around the same place his
birth dead in a godswood near a heart
tree even more poetically brans life was
saved using the very same dagger that a
cat's paw used during an attempt to
assassinate him way back in season 1
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]